like many of you i found modern warfare
2019 to be something special a different
take on call of duty that pulled off one
of the most energized and memorable
years in gaming in a long time then
modern warfare's multiplayer support
came to an abrupt end even felt like
it'd been cut short a season and black
ops cold war had its time to shine i
gave cold war a try but fell off it
pretty fast it was classic call of duty
style but i just still wanted new so
when call of duty vanguard was confirmed
to be a world war ii game from
sledgehammer i was a bit skeptical it
was gonna fill that void left behind by
modern warfare but early previews made
vanguard seem a bit more like a modern
warfare than cold war and i was happy to
jump in and give it a try i'm happy to
say that some parts really won me over
although other parts still feel behind
in this video we're going to explore how
vanguard draws influences from modern
warfare and if there's enough there to
stick with it as always give us a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel to join
us on this year's crazy journey that
will now see battlefield and call of
duty release within two weeks of each
other let's get to it
gun customization during this beta i
focused almost exclusively on the m1928
the tommy gun so i could get as far into
customization as possible and really
mess with gunsmith of all the mechanics
in vanguard gun customization impressed
me the most and feels similar to modern
warfare it wasn't that cold war didn't
have gunsmithing it's just it wasn't as
pronounced in that game you didn't feel
as many of those positive and negative
trade-offs vanguard has 10 slots open in
the beta compared to modern warfare's
five we're not sure yet if you'll be
able to use all 10 at launch or if you
need some kind of wild card to get there
but wow can you do a lot with a gun in
this game it just brought back the joy
of tinkering with weapons that i felt in
modern warfare i love the fact that you
can swap ammo barrels grips sights
stocks magazines and some other special
categories this system might even be an
improvement on modern warfare because it
lists the exact numbers and stats on how
things are affecting your gun to be fair
again that's something cold war also had
it's a great sandbox you can use your
wits to make something fantastic or just
utterly fail and make a bad gun but even
if you make a bad weapon you can fix it
by tinkering mid-match something in
modern warfare and cold war playing with
weapon builds adds a huge dimension to
call of duty and ammo types mean you can
completely change a gun's role mid-treat
that's a big incentive to keep grinding
it's not all roses though moment to
moment the guns and vanguards still feel
a little more arcady and a little less
tactical than modern warfare they were
just a bit easier to use and there's
always that risk of easy guns not
feeling as distinct and different from
each other if you want to know what i
mean just compare two fantastically
different lmgs from modern warfare the
absolute chonking rall
and the fast-firing and extremely
versatile fin with its chainsaw grip and
that barrel flaming out there aren't any
guns inside of one category in the
vanguard beta so far that feel that
dramatically different
thematically the gun customization makes
no sense it comes across like a world
war ii skin on top of modern warfare
rather than something that channels the
idea or spirit of a gritty world war ii
game i suppose this might be unavoidable
with the integration of these guns in a
war zone it's not a deal breaker it's
just not the kind of higher level art
you'd find in the game with a fully
realized theme the campaign level we saw
in a preview was very raw and brutal and
that just didn't carry to these
high-tech weapons
so now we need to talk about a war zone
subsection here under guns we're gonna
have to see how these weapons with 10
attachments perform in war zone compared
to weapons already in the battle royale
that have fewer attachments warzone was
notoriously broken by cold war's launch
integration that's because cold war's
guns were just easier to use than modern
warfare something i talked about a
minute ago with vanguard and because of
that some of them killed much faster and
were far deadlier in long range fights
and that just wasn't fair for some
players that meant games grinding to a
halt because people were unwilling to
move out in the open and take chances
time to kill has since been rebalanced
and weapons put on a more even playing
field but we could see the same
imbalance happen again with vanguard if
there isn't careful thought put into the
meta and honestly call of duty's kind of
pinned itself into a corner here by
committing to add so many new guns to
warzone with each launch it just doesn't
feel sustainable hopefully the new
warzone map coming alongside vanguard
will give us a do-over and to go just a
bit further on warzone vanguard is built
on a modified version of the modern
warfare engine and unlike cold war there
won't be any jarring transition and
mechanics between multiplayer and battle
royale you can do a lot of the same
things as in modern warfare like
mounting weapons aim down sights reloads
etc we still don't know if blind fire is
going to make it into war zone it
doesn't feel like a fully baked mechanic
yet though because you can't peek to see
what you're actually about to shoot at
it's very situational i luckily pulled
it off one time
double kill
and finally random but still not in
either modern warfare warzone or
vanguard is swimming and honestly it's
starting to bug me just a bit
[Music]
let's talk about maps the maps for
vanguard beta felt like the biggest step
back towards classic call of duty design
some like avirtue were bogg's standard 3
lane vs modern warfare's notoriously
poorest layouts that will appeal to core
call of duty fans but it started to feel
a little repetitive to me as a modern
warfare person after just one weekend
not all maps were the same though the
bottom of my list was hotel royal which
i found to either be too symmetrical or
too much of a mess in the middle and i
started to skip it at the top of my list
was red star which was much larger and
had tons of vertical and interior spaces
as well as this fountain straight out of
enemy of the gates across the board
though i felt like all the beta maps
could have been maybe 25 percent bigger
gevutu for example could probably open
up both shorelines and maybe that one
tower that's blocked off for some reason
but even though maps so far have been
generally smaller in size than modern
warfare there are a few clever tricks
that vanguard is experimenting with like
movable objectives on kavutu the b area
is a tank on an elevator that can be
raised and lowered and it's a lot of fun
to mess with the enemy team they can be
capturing it up on top and then you drop
it out from under them
another positive is that vanguard made
by sledgehammer also feels like it
channels some clever map routes more
commonly associated with infinity ward
style of design even the smallest modern
warfare maps have places you can learn
to get to and to be fair advanced
warfare by sledgehammer did have good
routes but they were light on the
exo-suit to use them hotel royal had
outer lanes you could access by jumping
the railings gevutu has a bunch of
different ways to get on the crash ship
and you could climb over or shoot under
a parked truck and redstar had a lot of
stacked boxes that gave you access to
higher stores in the building you could
climb over the rail cars or you could
jump out of certain places all these
maps to some degree gave slight
advantages to map knowledge
[Music]
destruction you know what i really like
doors in modern warfare they add a nice
element to the game where you don't
exactly know what's inside a building
and if you barge in the door slams open
and you give yourself away vanguard's
destruction isn't a huge thing on its
own but it does improve the door game
from modern warfare and seeing through
doors as they get chunked up can create
advantages or at least it looks really
cool the destructible walls in the game
are in fixed locations they don't really
have a large impact on matches but you
know as they get chewed up over time it
adds some pretty cool atmosphere i will
say your ability to kool-aid man your
way through them
didn't really make a lot of sense and
honestly kind of pulled me out of the
game a few times when it comes to
vanguard destruction isn't the main
course here it's like a bit of salt and
pepper on top bit of seasoning that's
the best way i can put it
let's talk about modes the vanguard beta
modes were all pretty standard call of
duty and i was really hoping for a
larger ground war mode alternative we
haven't seen one yet there hasn't been
one announced but that's kind of
confusing because the game has rocket
launchers but nothing really to launch
against
modern warfare is a lot more combined
arms than what we've seen in vanguard so
far what the game does have which is
interesting and potentially better than
modern warfare is variable combat pacing
that totally succeeds in making maps
more replayable in one playlist you
might see the same map in 6v6 10v10
14v14 or more the 14v14 range on larger
maps like red star was a genuine sweet
spot however some maps were
underpopulated in 6v6 and also had major
issues with spawn flipping with a raised
player count so it's still a work in
progress other than combat pacing patrol
mode was kind of interesting it's a
roving king of the hill and players have
to make a decision to get ahead of the
moving zone and let it come to them or
try and chase it from behind domination
and kill confirm feel very standard not
really a good or bad thing and team
deathmatch just doesn't work in my
opinion on many maps particularly with
lower player counts as in many other
call of duty games team deathmatch just
has no objective to dictate the flow of
matches leading to random wandering or
long sections where you don't find other
players and really only works on tiny
maps like modern warfare's cargo or
shipment when you're trying to grind out
a weapon tdm also just feels kind of
obsolete now compared to more focused
competitive modes like modern warfare's
gunfight and speaking of gunfights i
played a little bit of champion hell i'm
more curious how you all feel about it
though it seemed to be a kind of
gunfight gulag combo and i could see
competitive folks enjoying it but to me
it just felt like it lasted a little too
long
all right so let's talk about perks and
the impact on vanguard versus other call
of duty games one of the biggest things
to call attention to from perks and
vanguard is radar and that's because it
impacts the way the minimap works the
minimap has been in call of duty forever
and modern warfare initially tried to
get rid of it by replacing it with
incredible directional sound and other
visual indicators i really really like
that idea because to this day i still
don't like the fact that you have this
big beautiful game in front of you and
all you wind up doing is staring at this
square over in the corner
but many of you didn't feel that way and
modern warfare wound up having a
mini-map and also a fairly confusing
hybrid system of how you showed up on it
vanguard is another call of duty title
taking a stab at changing the minimap
having the minimap behave in classic
call of duty fashion is now a choice the
way it works in the beta is that you
only see people who shoot their weapons
unsilenced if you have radar equipped in
the perk 2 slot that means you need to
sacrifice some other type of situational
awareness like high alert forward intel
or tracker to take full advantage but to
make things complex again what
unsilenced means is more than one thing
for example the m1928 that i used a
bunch of this beta could take subsonic
rounds that keep you off the minimap
when you shoot it could also take a
suppressor which oddly enough didn't say
that it did the same thing so more
testing will be needed to see how you
actually stay off the minimap when
firing when it comes to kill streaks i
probably won't say much about them at
this point death machine was kind of
cool because it persisted between lives
but honestly there wasn't much to write
home about here versus being able to
drop an entire tank on some maps with a
kill streak in modern warfare modern
warfare also let players toggle between
kill streaks and score streaks which was
kind of cool i guess one random thing to
add here because i didn't have another
category to put it in is that vanguard
has teased a field of view slider coming
to console at launch it's been really
hard to go back from cold war to modern
warfare after having had that wider
field of view so if that's in the final
build of vanguard that will be a
technical leg up on modern warfare
there's a lot more to talk about with
vanguard we're getting an entirely new
warzone map and it's about time i'm
really hoping they take this chance for
a do-over from warzone because you can't
just keep adding 30 guns with every
release and expect a balanced meta
that's an impossible task so i want to
hear from you at this point does
vanguard appeal to you if you're a
modern warfare fan or if you're
following the latest news it now looks
like vanguard and battlefield 2042 will
release within two weeks of each other
so are you just gonna jump ship to
battlefield let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching
you